[Musique]
mais sachez que certains sont là aussi
réactiver
l'existant l'abrite oui
il n'y a pas non plus de responsables
sont utilisables
[Musique]
mais il y a une nette différence ici
de berlin comme la plupart des stations de métro
ici à berlin sont directement sous le
route construite à Berlin relativement
essayé assez rapidement pas cher
jusque dans les années 50 et 60
construire pour que les stations de métro de
une si faible profondeur qu'ils
contre les coups directs d'en haut
la station tout rien du tout
offrir une protection
Voyons, nous en avons plus à l'ouest
les gens qui se soucient vraiment de la forme
avoir une force nucléaire ou une attaque nucléaire
avons et nous avons à l'est
l'allemagne est dans le toujours nouveau
États fédérés il le peuple le
doigt est la guerre conventionnelle ou
vraiment très clairement la peur
avoir cela écrit devant la porte
il faut donc le dire très clairement et que
que vraiment maintenant avec le début de la
la guerre a encore augmenté
Mais cette peur doit être dite
[Musique]